Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Rachel Bernstein, who's an educator,
therapist, author, media and government consultant,
and also host of the weekly podcast Indoctrination.
And for over 30 years has been treating former
cult members and their families victims of
malignant narcissists, former supremacists,
conspiracy theorists, quite, quite a list.
Rachel, I appreciate you joining me today.
Speaker 5: Oh, it's my pleasure.
Thanks for asking me to be on.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, before we get into
some of the nitty gritty, how did it happen
that you started?
I don't know if you would necessarily call
it a focus, but that you started working in
this particular space with these types of
folks.
Speaker 5: Right.
Yeah.
It is most definitely a focus and it has remained
so.
And there was someone in my family who got
ensnared in a particular cultic group.
So it was kind of dinner table conversation.
And then when I went off to college, I had
already learned about some cults that use
front names on college campuses to get people
off of college campuses and kind of just take
them away.
Hmm.
And I saw them with my own eyes.
And, you know, first, when you hear about
cults, you're thinking someone's being a little
paranoid and maybe they're exaggerating.
And there it was.
And then when I went on to become a therapist,
I was noticing that there were a lot of people
who just didn't think they existed.
And I thought, I need to be a resource.
I need to be able to be out there to help
people when they have had this issue, because
it's very specific.
Speaker 1: When we talk about cults, for example,
to start with, there are dramatically different
scenarios when someone has already left the
cult and the support that they might need
at that point versus if someone is in the
cult and loved ones may be thinking more of
what is sometimes colloquially known as an
intervention.
Can you talk about whether you deal with both
or more of the after the fact only?
Speaker 5: Right.
So most of what I deal with is the after the
fact.
Although I am involved in some interventions,
these are non enforceable conversational style
interventions.
It's important that people know that so that
they don't get afraid of them, that it's not
at all that you're, you know, pulling up in
a van and putting someone in something that's
windowless and taking them away.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 5: It really is helping to educate
them about what they are involved in because
people involved in cults actually know the
least about them.
They have the least amount of access to the
information.
So all you're doing is informing them about
what's true.
But I'd say about 70% of the people I work
with have been out sometimes for a few days.
I mean, I've had people show up in my office
as they left that day and others who have
been out for years and realized that they
need help because there are so many triggers
that have been implanted that they didn't
realize until they got triggered.
Speaker 1: When I've interviewed former white
supremacists, for example, one of the trends
is that when they reflect on how they were
originally sucked in, they they all tell a
very similar story.
And it doesn't mean it's the only story, but
at least the ones I've spoken to have a similar
story, which is sort of opportunity caused
by usually problems at home, often with absent
parents or abusive parents, a sort of search
for meaning and inclusion from some kind of
group.
So sometimes there was bullying at school.
It's it's sort of circumstantial in terms
of the environment that they're in that makes
them vulnerable to the recruitment of some
of these supremacists.
Is that your experience?
And also, is it similar with the people that
get sucked into cults that may not be extremist
in that same way?
Speaker 5: Right.
So that has been my experience as well.
In addition to there is a timing factor.
So when people ask me what kind of person
gets involved in a cult, sometimes it is exactly
that that they're looking for something.
They're looking for meaning, they're looking
for connection community, for having a purpose.
They're trying to find some space for them
in the world, maybe in kind of parallel universe
because they haven't found their way in mainstream
society.
But for a lot of people, it's a timing issue.
They are away from home for the first time
or they just went through a trauma or they
were just diagnosed with something, or they
were just abused for the first time and they're
looking to escape that.
So I think a lot of factors actually play
into it.
Speaker 1: You've worked with the FBI on some
cases that maybe some in our audience are
familiar with.
One such cases, the Branch Davidians in Waco,
Texas, and the negotiations that took place
there.
Can you talk a little bit about.
What is such a negotiation process like?
What are the what are the principles that
are at play in such negotiations in those
situations?
Speaker 5: You know, those are interesting
times, certainly, because there is something
very incendiary about the moment.
And so you're kind of trying to beat the clock.
What you find when you're dealing with the
FBI or really any kind of government agency
is that you're trying to educate them about
what's different about this and how they need
to interact in a different way than they might
be thinking.
That doesn't always happen.
They don't always listen, unfortunately.
But you can give your idea about how to make
sure that they don't make people afraid of
leaving by doing what they're doing to get
them to come out.
I've been involved in a number of raids, not
planning them necessarily, but helping with
the aftermath and helping with people who
have been taken off compounds with the Branch
Davidians.
I use the information that I knew about what
would make people scared of leaving and to
and I think to really make them feel scared
of the world, which is what unfortunately
the ATF did by playing very loud music and
making them really feel overwhelmed.
And by kind of proving the cult leader right
about the world, unfortunately, that then
they stayed in.
But the other information I used was from
people who had escaped before the fire.
Some of the families, the parents, the children
who had been able to get out, who were also
guiding me about what they thought would be
the best sort of course of action for the
people still in it.
Sometimes they listen again and sometimes
not so much.
Speaker 1: So you mentioned you mentioned
the leaders, depending on which of which cult
one is talking about or extremist group.
Oftentimes the followers allow or may be accept
is the better word.
That their leaders play by a different set
of rules.
There's rules for the followers, and the leaders
often don't follow those very same rules.
Now, in cases like maybe a Jim Jones and the
People's Temple, it's he's seen sort of like
as a deity almost.
And so that makes it really easy to understand.
Well, like, if your God or God, like, of course,
you have a different set of rules that you
play by than we the followers play by.
But not all of these cults have leaders that
necessarily frame themselves in this kind
of deified way.
In the non overtly deifying cults.
What are the explanations or justifications
that the followers have for why the rules
they have to follow aren't the rules that
the leader has to follow?
Speaker 5: It's a great question.
It happens time and time again.
And to make this very relatable, this is something
that also happens in relationships with controllers
and with malignant narcissists, where they
can do whatever they want and you can't question
them and they can have access to your information
or your passwords or your, you know, ATM.
And they they can gain everything.
And you have nothing.
You have no power.
You can't get any of their information, but
they can get all of yours.
So it happens in these sort of one on one,
these sort of dyad cults, too, within these
relationships.
But going back to the idea of cults and why
permission is given, permission is given for
everything when it comes to the leader within
a cult.
And that's actually why some people start
cults, because they love that.
They love having the freedom to do or say
whatever they want, and they love knowing
that the rules only apply to the followers.
I mean, it's sort of, you know, the sociopaths
or the narcissistic playground and, you know,
they couldn't enjoy it more.
Unfortunately, what happens when you get involved
in a system like this is that there's kind
of what I see as a dual track of influence.
One is overt and one is covert.
And the overt is here are the teachings.
Here's what we believe in and here's what
you need to do to be a good follower.
The covert one is if you question how things
are run, you will not receive the benefit
of this.
All of your sacrifice will be for naught,
right?
Your time is going to be wasted.
If you are questioning the fact that I have
44 Rolls-Royces, like with Rajneesh, and you
get nothing and you sleep on the floor, then
that negativity is going to get in the way
of you receiving what I'm trying to give you.
And you need to question yourself.
People learn how to turn the focus inward
within a cult, and they question themselves
for doubting and doubting and being negative.
Being angry about anything or resenting anything
in a cult is considered really, really awful.
And it's going to be counterproductive to
what you're trying to get by being there.
So you think you're working against yourself
by having critical thinking?
It's a fascinating kind of way of getting
into gaslighting.
Speaker 1: When I've spoken to experts on
conspiracy theories, sometimes the idea comes
up of like more destructive or dangerous conspiracy
theories versus ones, ones that are sort of
like more benign.
And sometimes there will be this contrast
where it's like, you know, some of the anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories that lead people to seek
out and do violence against Jewish people.
Very dangerous.
On the other hand, believing the earth is
flat, not so dangerous.
And to some degree, every conspiracy theory
expert that I talked to says, yes, in the
overt sense it's true that one is much more
dangerous than the other.
At the same time, rarely is there only one
conspiratorial belief.
These things open doors to more and more extreme
beliefs.
And so we should be careful to say this one
is totally benign.
We don't need to worry about it.
When we think about that as applied to cults,
are there what we might call not very dangerous
cults?
Like, for example, I read an article not long
ago about how CrossFit or like Peloton or
SoulCycle, they have a lot of the elements
on paper of a cult, but it's not really dangerous
in the way that a lot of these others are.
Can you talk a little bit about that and kind
of categorizing these?
Speaker 5: Right.
So yeah, there are some cult groups that are
more dangerous than others, undoubtedly.
And it all depends upon the leader.
It depends where the leader wants to take
it and what the leader needs in terms of ego
aggrandizement.
If they want to just test you to see what
you're willing to do for them because it makes
them feel powerful, then they will sometimes
push you to the brink.
They'll push you to the point where it's not
healthy for you, it's actually dangerous for
you just because they want to see you struggling
because they told you to.
And I think that when you're dealing with
cults that are dangerous, you're dealing with
cults where they will tell you, for example,
like a lot of the ones that deal with pseudoscience,
where here we have the cure for you.
So people bypass actual cures.
Things that could really help them in order
to get what the cult leader or that person
is telling them they need and they end up
not doing well or they end up not living,
but they've already signed their rights away.
And so there's nothing that they can do about
it.
And so, yes, when you're engaging in anything
that feels like someone's giving you the cure,
it can be potentially very, very dangerous.
And there can be a lot of medical neglect
actually in those situations.
The other is when people are finding themselves
getting more militaristic and they're talking
about the end times, they're talking about
survival.
That's when you get into a lot more of the
stockpiling of weapons of also needing to
see the world and the people in it as less
than as not human anymore, and that you're
above them when you have that polarization
and you have a lot of danger.
Speaker 1: Last thing generally that I want
to talk about and there's a lot here is get
getting people out right.
We know when it comes to false beliefs, generally
beating people over the head with facts doesn't
really work very well.
You know, we've had dozens of guests where
we talk about that in one way, shape or form.
Empathy is good.
Understanding is good.
Communicating that the person's not going
to be shamed if they decide, Oh, you know
what, I was wrong about this thing.
I want to get out making clear that they're
going to have the resources with Scientologists.
That's the big thing where they have nothing.
And so part of staying in is I'm going to
have literally nothing if I get out of here.
In terms of the getting out, you mentioned
sometimes the people in the cult know the
least about the cult.
I don't necessarily need to.
One thing I sometimes think about is in conversations
with Mormons and there's different opinions
about whether Mormonism is a cult.
But let's at least consider the possibility
it might be cult like many Mormons.
Don't know that Joseph Smith, each time he
read the gold tablets or whatever they are.
It was a different reading and he had a history
of being a con man and all these different
things that they just don't know that.
And simply telling them that that's a reality
is not going to be convincing if you just
kind of give them that information.
So what are the right ways to communicate
the information that they might be lacking?
Because we know, just like, hey, here's a
bunch of stuff about your beliefs doesn't
really work.
Speaker 5: Right?
I'm so glad you asked this question because
this is most of the work that I do helping
to have the conversation that's difficult
to have with someone who might not be ready
to look at the fact that they were involved
in a cult and also helping guide families
and friends and spouses to know how to have
these conversations so as not to kind of,
you know, push them further back in and make
them feel alienated, judged, etc..
Right.
So one of the things you want to be able to
do is you want to engage them in a conversation
about what they liked about it.
Let them know that you're going to be fair
minded about this, that there must have been
a reason that they got involved.
What was the promise?
What did they think they could get?
And maybe who did they meet, who they liked,
etc.?
So that you're not just going in for the kill,
you're not just going in to talk about what
was bad, because if you do, then they're going
to feel foolish.
They're going to feel like if it was all bad,
why did I get involved?
Why did I stay?
Yeah.
So talk about what they got now or really
talk about what they were promised that they
probably still didn't get because there's
always the carrot that's dangled.
So you get a sense of sort of what they were
searching for, what is part of their value
system, what they wanted to cure in the world,
what they wanted to cure about themselves,
and then let them know that you have information
and let them know that they can listen to
it or not they can disagree with it or not,
but that this is information you want to give
to them out of respect for them, that this
was something that was kept from them.
But people should have access to information
so they can make a fully informed decision.
And you let them know that if they feel like
they want to go back, they can go back there.
There have been plenty of times that I've
done an intervention where the person has
gone back.
But because I said, Listen, I'm glad you're
saying that you're not involved in a cult
just in case.
Let me just give you a rundown of what a cult
is and what happens there.
And they could disagree with me in the moment,
but they went back.
It's like I planted a seed.
They went back and they saw these things for
themselves so they could come out on their
own terms.
And so if the person doesn't feel judged,
if they really are able to maintain the sense
that you see them as capable, you see them
as bright, you see them as people who are
not just gullible people, then you are going
to be able to have a much more successful
conversation and then say, I have information.
You can also share me and share information
with me about your group, and I will share
information about it too, that I've heard
so that there really is a reciprocity to the
conversation.
Speaker 1: Super, super interesting.
We've been speaking with Rachel Bernstein,
who is an educator, therapist and author.
She also.
Hosts the weekly podcast Indoctrination.
Rachel, really a pleasure having you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Thank you so much for having me
on.
Good to talk to you.